[Musica]
salve youtubers prima di iniziare la
recensione del cinema lettone finalmente
vorrei ringraziare alessandro quello che
mi ha fatto la la nuova grafica del
canale grazie grazie grazie grazie mille
e fantastica l'hai fatta veramente
benissimo e vorrei pubblicizzarlo per
ringraziarlo il canale se volete
iscrivervi fa dei tutorial per after
effects in italiano molto molto belli il
canale lo trovate nelle informazioni del
mio cane nel mio canale sotto in basso
detto questo
possiamo iniziare
non sapevo bene come farla questa
recensione detto quali battute faccio
quali punti recensisco quale film
recensisco allora io vi ho fatto tirare
tutta la lista ho letto quasi no tutti i
commenti tutte le e mail che mi avete
mandati tutti i messaggi privati
allora molti di voi hanno votato all è
però non so perché ho deciso di di
scartarlo diciamo perché l'ho visto e mi
è sembrato
stupido ma ce n'è e ce n'è uno ancora
più stupido che molti hanno votato
perché è arrivato in seconda posizione
ed è nata al in india ok però vorrei
dire che questa recensione vale per
tutti i cinepanettoni che almeno tutti
quelli che ho visto da vacanze di natale
fino a natale a new york che mi sembra
che sia l'ultimo che ho visto allora
partiamo subito con i cinque punti
perché non voglio perdere altro tempo
numero 5 la storia io rimpiango alex
l'ariete ebbene sì l'ho citato per due
recensioni di fila elogiandolo elogio di
nuovo io rimpiango alex l'ariete nella
storia perché faceva schifo la storia ma
almeno c'era la storia era
brutta ma c'era qui no c'è se noi
leggiamo la trama su wikipedia o su
qualche altro sito di film
riusciamo ci si racconta delle cose che
sono situazioni montate insieme per
tirare un film di un'ora e mezza sono
situazioni e la maggior parte neanche
quelle la maggior parte sono greg più
che situazioni sono jack
appiccicate insieme con lo sputo perché
ai due personaggi nasce un figlio tutti
e due fanno in india c'è il caso
giudiziario
ma non c'è una vera e propria trama
consistente c'è che tu aspetti di sapere
come va a finire perché non va dice se i
film si fermasse a metà sarebbe uguale
identico perchè non essendoci trama va
benissimo qualsiasi cosa
numero 4
stereotipi che cosa sono gli stereotipi
stereotipi sono quel tipo di
caratterizzazione dei personaggi che
così da decenni ormai miei film c'è il
burino deve essere sempre volgarissimo
finalmente per scovato la chianina che
se fred c'è il magistrato giudice che
deve fare per forza yoga e tutto il
resto
ma dove vai doveva anche ha preparato un
gatto di soia da leccarsi i baffi è
tipico del gatto le carte i baffi il
rapper deve essere per forza sopra le
righe il fumato deve essere per forza
sopra le righe
i fichi d'india beh i fichi d'india se
tu devi usare gli stereotipi per far
ridere in un film vuol dire che sei
veramente ma veramente senza idee perché
voi pensate ad aldo giovanni e giacomo
aldo giovanni giacomo fanno dei
personaggi nelle nei loro film ma sono
sempre i loro stessi cioè se andò fa un
un carcerato e aldo ad essere un
carcerato non è che aldo interpreta un
carcerato e al doppio per adesso è un
cancello perché è la sua personalità
messa nel personaggio di un che di un
carcerato infatti loro non puntano sulla
caratterizzazione dei personaggi ma
sulla storia e sulle battute dentro la
storia perché le battute di aldo
giovanni giacomo sono infilate
egregiamente all'interno della trama
come ho detto prima la trama in natale
in india non c'è quindi le battute sono
completamente slegate sono messe lì
giusto come riempitivo
ripeto usare gli stereotipi per cercare
di fare libere e infantile ma infantile
veramente tutte le cose di questo film
sono infantili c'è nel senso che
farebbero ridere un infante
numero 3
enzo salvi perché se ti sei come ti
chiami del genere è una domanda che
portano a 9 con me e io mi chiamo yoga
tornantino mio a roviano
addio alla roma di un manubrio ma cosa
ci fai qui i miei genitori erano due bis
di ostia e sono tenute inizia per le
rate
evviva il pisa casi man abbandonava qui
a fini dei fiori no sfida la [__]
[Musica]
numero due
la comicità lavoro è questo il più
grande problema del film che non fa
ridere o meglio non è che ci hanno
provato e non fa ridere no non fa ridere
basta perché almeno a me non fa ridere
quindi ripeto le mille recensioni sono
per come la vedo io quindi se non siete
d'accordo
non me frega mente per dirci queste sono
mie opinioni non fa ridere perché come
ho detto prima sono tutte gag infantili
ma troppo infantili che
vanno a toccare sempre il sesso però in
modo volgarissimo parolacce tante
parolacce
il giudice con rispetto parlando mi
perdoni la volgarità ma lei mi ha fatto
riempire il cazzo di te la pesca
guardate per esempio aldo giovanni e
giacomo le parola ce li ci sono ma sono
in un contesto naturale c'è la battuta
lì ci stava come l'avremmo fatta stare
noi cioè se io fossi stato insieme a
giovanni e giacomo e mentre parlavamo
scappava la battuta deve dire ma che
cazzo fai io avrei detto ma che cazzo
fai è giusto così come hanno fatto loro
qui sono forzatissime giusto per cercare
di far ridere il telespettatore e ride
il telespettatore questo il problema
come fanno secondo voi i cinepanettoni a
guadagnare milioni di euro milioni
perché la gente ma a vedervi a una cosa
che non sapeva quasi nessuno secondo voi
perché nel resto del mondo avatar è il
film non film di james cameron costato
tipo 400 milioni di dollari o giù di lì
è uscito in tutto il mondo lotto di
dicembre mentre da noi uscirà a wish we
uscito il 15 di gennaio secondo me
perché
non lo so forse perché a natale cioè il
periodo in cui due uscite avatar sarebbe
uscita natale a beverly hills e allora
hanno fatto hanno detto eh no ma la
concorrenza con avatar sarebbe stata
spietata perché tutti sarebbero andati a
vedere natale a beverly hills e nessuno
avatar e quindi abbiamo deciso di far
uscire dopo così tutti sarebbero potuti
andare a vedere sia uno che l'altro
bugiardi pezzi di merda e lo sapete
benissimo che non è vero che è così
avete il contrario tutti sarebbero
andati a vedere avatar viene solo
sarebbe andato a vedere quella schifezza
che ci propina te ogni natale avete
fatto bene a spostarlo bravi complimenti
ma questa è una cosa che si può fare c'è
in tutto il mondo non l'hanno fatto l'ha
fatta da noi ma stiamo scherzando e poi
dicono di non mandarli a cagare ma come
fai a non mandarli a creare il proprio
te li tirano le parolacce riprendendo il
discorso della comicità
non so che altro dire c'è il rapper
vomito dovrebbe far ridere il vomito fa
ridere le scoregge fanno così tanto
ridere la massima metteteci dentro di
tutto e mi raccomando tanto per poi la
comicità è l'arma di distruzione di
massa
metteteci anche una bella pisciata di
più è venuto un certo languorino a pane
e o fare anch'io
adesso vedo si trova delle bacche delle
radici marassi piscetta volontà così
riuscirete finalmente a fare ridere i
bambini di due anni ma sì io mi immagino
il regista carlo vanzina o anche neri
parenti con pannolino cioè loro sono
angol pannolino allora la baby e la
cacca fa ridere per loro fa ridere i
rutti le scoregge fatto ridere ma già
che ci siete perché non ci mettete anche
una bella cagata
numero uno
la cacca stop giardinetto la torre
ancora non ha fatto nemmeno una bambina
molto strana perché di solito che certi
tiri nelle banane certi lo vedo perchè
ci sono così tante battute sulla cacca
io non riesco a capire perché la cacca
dovrebbe fare ridere
h guarda come siamo veneti siamo veneti
della merda nascosi sono le dispiace
signora orfei ad eseguire un centrale
merda e ironico che in un film di merda
ci siano battute sulla cacca comunque e
kakà c'è che cos'è la cacca nelle siamo
un attimo le feci gli escrementi
gli scriventi vengono espulsi dal nostro
corpo vengono espulsi dal nostro corpo
perché sono in eccesso sono scorie del
cibo e sali minerali eccetera che vanno
espulsi puzzano non si possono mangiare
vanno espulsi no i registi di questi
dannati film maledetti cell e lanciano
al traverso del serbo cina non c'era la
cacca addosso per far ridere ci lanciano
a kakà
qui io non posso non incazzarmi
impossibile perché se tu usi la cacca
per
pronto si
conservi le salve
ok ok riferisco io ok non si preoccupi
arrivederci arrivederci
film era per te erano tutti i
telespettatori che ti guardano mi hanno
detto di dirti che
buoni
e se tu telespettatore riesce a vivere
per una cosa del genere o ai 5 anni o ai
la cacca il cervello
come fai a non uscire matto dopo queste
cose c'è mi spiego come fai a non uscire
matto dopo aver visto queste cose è
impossibile l'unica cosa che puoi fare
qui è suicidarsi ma purtroppo io non
vedo da
grazie mano destra